you've gotta hit that you go
oh [ __ ] you bad [ __ ] tonight's
your lucky night if you're under 18 hang
up now it's the Church of what's
happening now pre periscope [ __ ]
launch off tonight's the night strap on
your [ __ ] seat buffs cuz we're going
deep [ __ ] you understand me if you
haven't been to rehab you will be after
this evening for different things we got
everything
oh [ __ ] of death oh look what else we
got
[Music]
you got some stars you know how we do it
though just to open up you're gonna give
us your little restaurant you don't need
one thing you open up with a salad maybe
blue cheese with onions and the [ __ ]
chopped salad maybe a shrimp cocktail
and then you get the aperitif that's
what we do here on the church we mix
them mingle a couple things you want to
see how many stars of death we have
tonight eleven and we will split right
down the middle here oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
with a tail and a crooked that's like a
[ __ ] with a cockeyed you know I'm
saying it with this shot
can she suck a dick look at that eye
it's crooked I'm saying you do the
[ __ ] math not suffice whoa-hoo for 6
we're going deep in this bag tonight
Buster's sugar cubes plus the liquid CID
plus we got some other [ __ ] edibles
kaput
we got a double there you go open up
with [ __ ] but just like that and you
know what this is right oh [ __ ] you take
this ice cube you go like this no yeah
you're gonna go for right now mixed with
the [ __ ] straw with the dead stop
surrenders listen man you've been lied
to for years all these [ __ ] people
they see the stars they're that [ __ ]
travelers they don't do dick like uncle
Joey not that none of you [ __ ]
none of them do what me and Lee are
doing over here
so put that into your [ __ ] notebook
[ __ ]
[Music]
got like that it's a sugar cube when you
can't be its water water sugar sent
intravenous what's that
who do you think your luck what a fight
why do you think I do the things I do to
studs it and the pain is over
no biggest a fixer look at this night we
got a couple [ __ ] taffy these
terrible [ __ ] joints these things
don't do nothing they stick up your
house like bad in senses [ __ ] I don't
like joints from stores
[Music]
what the [ __ ] I do it your life huh
we also got some wacky Taffy's we were
hitting it from all angles today I'm Sam
this is like [ __ ] will I need it and
that's not gonna do nothing for you try
to tell you people tonight's your lucky
[ __ ] night the Super Bowl is over
Brady is at home right now eating [ __ ]
eighteen ways from Tuesday you
understand me they're shoving little
footballs up his ass the Atlanta Falcons
you played a great game nothing to be
ashamed about right you went up against
the [ __ ] kings of Swing was due here
but we're here with quit the football
was yesterday
your future is what important to me I'm
saying how you gonna put it together
hang on lay it down and how you gonna
keep it there once it's in there you
follow me we'll get poor leaves over
there having a good time we heard even
boys threw off on the chocolate yeah
that's will save nephal is dessert like
the chocolate cake it more than 200,000
about 2,000 milligrams tonight maybe
some acid forget about your lucky with
it tonight you seem sad I love you
[ __ ] not you this wouldn't be
possible so we go the extra mile here I
can tell you about how we do this and we
do that you don't do nothing we do it so
you can see it we don't [ __ ] do it in
salmon sea but we could be lying to me
all these mushroom people a gram a Nate
no no believe mushrooms don't know don't
believe that uncle Joey's here we take
it to the hoop for you if not why talk
if you can't be [ __ ] honest with
these [ __ ] people home town that's it
next up we got every clap to slow him
that's some great album [ __ ] tonight
well I've o'clock the Slowhand
Dante ghazini gave me Southside Johnny
doing Tom wait covers the essential
Johnny Cash from my brother in Nashville
Willie Nelson [ __ ] friends I
mean you know person it's a good night
to get [ __ ] up God if you were
thinking of getting [ __ ] up tonight
guys tonight all the amateurs will not
last night you go out to a bar they see
a girl with a mace good she sucking dick
there's no amateur hour at him last
night that was amateurs this is Super
Bowl oh my god there's a party they made
nachos get the [ __ ] out of my face
nobody want little things that Benson
maybe one I said [ __ ] this all these
people thought about a place here poking
out of place here you don't say D you
wanna go get Dean Delray body starts
early timing to get back with to 1000
some chocolates I don't think he got
away with murder Jesus Christ he's
banging his head that matters won't you
stay with me
[Music]
what the savage is that when this
[ __ ] is that shit's going off I'm
saying this earth is doing that
I never seen nobody do not I'm saying
I'll fall it [ __ ] [ __ ] and you guys
[Music]
it's the goods it's the [ __ ] goods
nothing beats smoking [ __ ] reefer
night you [ __ ] out all not your
stupid [ __ ] pills nothing you control
it you buy to the [ __ ] store and you
know what everybody sleeps at night
nobody gets a beating for reefer
well it's somebody show up with a black
guy over reefer don't [ __ ] happen
don't there's no drama drunk right here
and I [ __ ] love it
how's that for you cuz Cleveland
something's made it in Cleveland for the
church specifically mmm this is for you
and this is a weapon and a pipe at the
same time plus if the Sun gets going go
[ __ ] up you could finger bang somebody
with this [ __ ] thing it's over
they'll come back again on Tuesday
that's the way we do it here oh [ __ ] no
worries it happens
and that's it we're here with that with
this with that boy every [ __ ]
direction little boy lately ready for
the chocolate of love this is a good job
it's this beautiful right here look how
nice and loose it is no neither piece
yeah the whole [ __ ] bar this
formaldehyde we got everything on this
bar here we got the [ __ ] that made
Charles Manson kill 18 people this is
the chocolate here delicious [ __ ] you
get in French what's the kind of [ __ ]
you buy from terrorists in France on the
streets and [ __ ] after their shooting
people they sell these door-to-door
realize yourself mister it's never to it
[Music]
you know undercover this one day we
robbed in Spanish beat him and smile
super hard to find
you don't crazy yeah I got the jiggle of
the helm of a guy's a cop okay
David Lee Roth in Spanish comes up is
super rounds that's a deep double shut
up waste I'm saying way that much is
here is a professional development
this is rival sentence head down smoke a
record oh [ __ ] oh and I got a Christmas
present him with me oh yeah oh look at
this [ __ ] Christmas I've been holding it
at the type of [ __ ] I is you
understand me
I gotta open that and sold it on the
black market and got a small $8 see what
that is this [ __ ] some gentlemen cool
[ __ ]
oh yeah my god vine oh [ __ ] you wanted
it you got it come suck the wisdom aside
choke well you had a little problems
then what somebody you get anxiety don't
puke it's a ho-hum night here on
destruction is raining all day you rode
your bike
I'm trusted but rain out here in
Southern California the B Jordan is
there was a smorgasbord of death tonight
understand it was better than Chinese
buffet we hit it from all angles the sit
on the sugar cube
stars the debt taffy Watney chocolate
listen normal people don't live like
that but that's why we do this cuz we
ain't normal
we did a bust the [ __ ] bank
understanding BAM
you see I'm saying we're already getting
warmed up yeah we'll see you in 10
minutes on youtube.com I see /c / Joey
Diaz again that's youtube.com / c / Joey
beers like I said if you're under 18
hang up now concept you know how to
watch this type of [ __ ] abuse we're
here we'll quit it
we'll be back in 10 15 minutes alright
get it together
we love you [ __ ]